milchbubi schüchtern von außen aber im
wagner da nannte er sich super moderator
lud ein kinderporno video ein
kinderporno foto nach dem nächsten hoch
und das über jahre so lange bis
schließlich die gsg9 sein kinderzimmer
stürmt heute prozessauftakt und dort war
mit dabei bild reporter jörg völkerling
jonas es jörg dieser ja milchbubi habe
ich gerade gesagt wir sehen in ihr
versteckt sein gesicht hinter den
aktenordnern wie hast du ihn zum
prozessauftakt erlebt der 19 jährige
angeklagte wurde heute morgen hier am
amtsgericht amberg von zwei vor für
beamten aus seiner zelle vorgeführt er
verbarg sein gesicht hinter einem
aktenordner und begrüßte nur kurz auf
dem flur seiner mutter als sich die
türen dann geschlossen hatten legte er
ein umfangreiches geständnis ab vor
allen dingen um den vier hunde denen er
per whatsapp chattete und von ihnen
nackt fotos erpresste eine aussage vor
gericht zu ersparen
die anklage der cybercrime
staatsanwaltschaft bamberg ist 18 seiten
lang und sehr detailliert diakonie hat
eingeräumt als moderator als
administrator in verschiedenen forum
erfuhren aktiv gewesen zu sein
er soll in 167 online sitzung über 2.600
kinderpornografische bilder hochgeladen
haben und hat das heute hier bedauert
und hat aber auch gesagt er habe
aussucht um anerkennung in diesem tag
net foren gehandelt was war seine
motivation wollte er mit den kinderfotos
internet geld verdienen
nein also ein finanzielles motiv konnte
ihm die staatsanwaltschaft nicht
nachweisen tatsächlich hat mir sein
verteidiger bernhard löwenberg im
vorfeld gesagt dass es ihm einfach nur
um seine art von sozialkontakten ging er
sein wird gewesen der sich nächtelang
vor seinem computer die zeit vertrieben
habe und sei letztlich dem sammeln druck
erlegen habe immer mehr bilder sozusagen
gehortet
in einem forum soll besonders
privilegierte mitglieder mussten 1 gb
daten material hochgeladen werden um
überhaupt zugang zu erlangen das hatte
jakob gemacht er habe sich viele dieser
bilder wohl gar nicht angeguckt im
vorfeld sondern einfach nur immer mehr
material haben wollen und so sei es dann
über einen zeitraum von zwei jahren zu
dieser wirklich unglaublichen daten
gängige kommen konnten denn durch die
ermittlungen gegen den jetzt angeklagten
weitere kinderschänder überführt werden
ja die hinweise auf jakob ii kamen durch
ermittlungsbehörden in neuseeland
australien und den usa wohl auch aus
frankreich und als die gsg 9 an einem
abend kurz nach mitternacht am 29 januar
vergangenen jahres und das elternhaus
von jakob eindrang ging es ja darum
ihnen sozusagen anrufe nimmt zu
erwischen
jacobi soll aber auch sofort sehr
kooperativ gewesen sein er sagte ihnen
seinen nutzernamen prisoner er gab ihnen
seine passwörter so dass einfach
nachvollzogen werden konnte welche foren
er dort betrieb und benutzte und auf
diese weise war es in der vergangenheit
auch immer so dass die cybercrime
ermittler weiteren kinderschändern auf
die spur gekommen sind mit einem sehr
bekannten teilte sich jacobi in bamberg
sogar eine zelle das war oliver h der
logopäde der im vergangenen jahr wegen
missbrauchs von kindern der
kindertagesstätte zu über elf jahren
haft verurteilt worden war
harte strafen hier kann man sich in
solchen fällen als vater immer nur
wünschen was es da eine einschätzung
nach diesem prozesstag wie lange wird er
ja möglicherweise hinter gittern landen
wir verhandeln hier vor dem
jugendschöffengericht des amtsgerichts
am berg
weil manche der taten stattfanden als
der angeklagte noch minderjährig war
ich würde das ganze nicht öffentlich
verhandelt es sind nur zwei
verhandlungstage bis morgen geplant als
zeuge ist nur der ermittlungsführer
geladen morgen sagt der psychiatrische
gutachter aus der dem angeklagten
bereits eine pädophile neigung
attestiert hat aber sich nicht für eine
unterbringung in einer klinik ausspricht
damit stehen bis zu vier jahre haft im
raum steht aber auch die frage im raum
nach einer mitverantwortung der behörden
denn jacoby hatte seine neigung seine
schädliche neigung sehr wohl erkannt
auch ein arzt hatte wohl schon eine
therapie empfohlen und auch dem
jugendamt einen hinweis gegeben
schon über ein jahr vor der festnahme
doch diesem hinweis ist man wohl nicht
gefolgt jedenfalls fand sich kein
therapieplatz für jakob i
wir sind bild und wir liefern die
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren